[Music]
20 international chess professionals
converge in st. Louis for the 2017 fall
chess classics the fall chess classic is
over and we have a champion but it
wasn't decided the normal way we had to
go to playoffs
in what was a very exciting and long day
the final round of group a saw all games
end in draws which meant that two
players stood atop Georg Meyer of
Germany and st. Louis's own yaroslav's
Arabic both players would have to engage
in a playoff the format for the playoff
was too rapid games that's game in ten
with a two second increment if that
series was tied one to one they would
play a best-of to blitz series that's
five minutes with a two-second increment
and if that was tied well then they
would have to go to a blitz Armageddon
history was made here in Group A of the
fall chess classic for the first time in
this classic series we went to a playoff
there were two players at the top and
guess who won
it's this guy grandmaster georg meyer
the champion of group a congratulations
on your playoff victory i mean i know
the Adrenaline's still flowing how are
you feeling right now I'm just pleased
with my performance I mean there was
only one game in the whole tournament
where I had Judas regrets it was when I
didn't beat neuro the skin yesterday but
otherwise things were going well and
mostly in the tiebreak I was also
playing well except for one time where I
got really low on time and got punished
for this oh my gosh and that that that
third game that was just nerves
personified right there
but let's so the format first we had we
were guaranteed to rapid games game in
ten with a two second increment and if
it wasn't decided there then we go to
blitz and while we did so let's take a
look at some of the moments starting in
sequence with the first game
yeah well especially in tiebreaks I just
stick to my various solid openings with
Knight f3 g3 well the classical games I
do mix it up a bit more so we got some
symmetrical Greenfeld which must have
had hundreds of times also in blitz and
eventually after exchanging some pieces
we go to this position which is about
equal so his point was that I cannot
hang on to my pawn on f4 sorry Bishop c4
I cannot hang on to the pawn on f4
because Queen d7 is a sweet double
attack against g4 and f4 so I decided to
just bring my Bishop into the game and
from here Yaroslav started lost threat
of the position because obviously this
rook on f4 is actually standing quite
awfully since I mean it cannot do
anything against the structure with
every and the bishop on before and he
decided to put another look through the
useless a file and now I've nice way to
get the initiative opening up the
position and now I'm threatening to play
rock c7 and it's quite hard to do
anything about it
the computer is showing that the only
defense is quintic c7 which I didn't
really consider but I also didn't have
to but instead with the clock ticking
down Yaroslav immediately panicked with
g5 I saw some nice line with Queen d4
and here black wants to take on f2 but
actually I can liquidate and so I think
a winning weekend again because Marik is
also gonna sit on this B pond so that
black is completely tied down
so after g5 basically a one on the spot
since now I'm on the seventh rank and
here's a weakness on f4 no no
coordination to speak of so I think the
position is just lost in two he resigned
so that of course was a great start for
me and now Yara was forced into a
must-win situation you can't draw or
else you get the victory the match
victory and the tournament so let's take
a look at game two and this was kind of
fun he played a free and then I fought
for a moment and I thought okay let's
play white again Knight of 6 g6 and I do
what I usually do so I think he just
wanted to get a random position to make
me think so did later on in time trouble
he could hope for some chances and this
is pretty much what happened although I
think I was positionally just winning it
up on the clock and then if I hadn't
fallen I slipped and I should wrap up
the match here but okay it's a
tiebreaker and such things happen so
here I'm already positionally better
with film control of a dark squares in
the center I just decided to play very
safely not to force any matters and yeah
this is just an extremely pleasant
position with no weaknesses for black
great pieces and even the a pawn that is
quite weak
so here I I basically missed his
rejoined or I should just play Queen d7
then rue k-8 and he has no activity at
all instead a play at night before I
basically fought the time already
closing out again attacking on d3 but
you found this very nice trick night b5
and now if I take on d3
I actually don't manage to salvage the
material everything is under attack
so I went back losing to Tempe and now
of course he gets a little bit of play
although I still have a decent position
and ok so we continue like this and now
we were down too soon seconds and I'm
still positionally almost winning but I
mean he's at least looking at making and
then in time trouble I just collapsed
so here Ruka for I literally plays with
one second remaining on the clock and
the next most replayed instantly and
then I resigned and we of Queen g7 rook
takes effect mate the tension in the
room when that happened was I was so
high it was like oh my goodness so yaro
did it and he forced a guaranteed to to
game blitz match so the match continued
yeah but I wasn't really shaking I was
you know just upset that falling asleep
at a good position but I'm a very good
blitz player so I wasn't worried at all
about my chances right and in euros
attitude was very much of relief in the
room he was wiping his brow like yeah
and basically and the Blitz had changed
a little bit my attitude because seeing
what happened in that last game I
decided to clear and I must play quickly
and practically and not look for the
best move too often just play solidly
and wait for my chance
so here we had some Queens gambit and
got some normal position and well he
already something went wrong for him
because after 25 you cannot move the F
pawn I have this cute trick and I just
win two pawns for nothing so I had to go
back of course I realized very
comfortably but here I basically miss
this Bishop Essex and I cannot take on
f3 because my my rook will be trapped
now the CI truck has nowhere to go so
like I said I didn't mind just go back
don't waste too much time thinking about
what I did wrong and still deck is
extremely solid probably not better but
I like that I have two more compact bone
structure and especially in a blitz
candid that means it's easier for me to
play so I was trying to exchange pieces
and now he allowed me and what is
settled with some weaknesses now if I've
c4 even a two and at least practically
speaking a very much like blacks
position here because the knight is
trying to go to f5 and then I can just
start and hang the c4 pawn so
now a taxi forint already white is very
bad coordination interior I was thinking
if I should take on g3 and basically
he's forced to take with the pawn with a
bad bone structure to keep c4 protected
but I realized that his coordination is
so awful that I should just exchange the
Queen's and then I can start picking up
on so on the Queen side so I played
Queen d7 and now it was very easy so he
he was desperate enough to even allow me
to take on if we just saw that he gets
rid of the knight but it's too much
because now at every move I will attack
his weak bones and basically I picked
them all up here this one even with
second son he resigned so that that was
a very confident victory I think and it
brings us to the last game and once
again yarrow finds himself in a must-win
situation to force an Armageddon so he
was struggling to find some setup again
so to make me think a little but I'm
very experienced with the system
especially in blitz so I usually have
some idea what to do quickly so he's
trying not to have any tension in the
center just to be flexible but
eventually he'll run out of moves
because if he continues like this then I
will have f5 and potentially his six
coming disrupting his his hulking side
plate c5 which just position will be
quite ugly
since now all the Queen side has full of
faults from black and yeah
White is just comfortably better and
even with logical Musa I'm trading
pieces okay I was not trying to prove
any advantage but I saw that here I'm
very safe and just trained for this
and here I think his only chance must
play Queen f7 here because he has kind
of a double attack attacking the Fife
and threatening to take over the e-file
and I wasn't yet sure what what I would
do here but obviously not not much as
happening still I mean no not this even
if I love to play rook e8 I can still do
this since he can't really take the pawn
on d5 because I have Queen e7 check at
the end and now he has to give me a pawn
back end which is open King there is
simply nothing he can do in terms of
playing for a win and he played Queen f7
and now I could immediately shut down
the game with rocky 6 so if you go take
on d5 I just take on d6
and here obviously white is just better
with the past pawn on e6 but my
objective was simply to make a draw from
here just to be solid and that was not
too difficult now it's basically over
because open structures fixed and there
was no way he can approach my six pawn
and 12 we made some moves but here I was
happy to just force a draw but I could
also play is-7 and force him to resign
on the spot but at that point it doesn't
matter mercy he said two and a half to
one and a half but it's enough it's
enough to win the Fall Classic on tie
breaks are on playoffs rather so Gehrig
I know that you're you're all out about
in the chess world where can the people
find you on the Internet
I did start a Twitter account not so
long ago so if you put my name you'll
find me hopefully I will start tweeting
a bit more and I used to play a lot on
Chester common language now recently and
not so much but usually people will see
me there every mountain but the website
I don't have so far I imagine that you
are playing and are you playing on the
spice Cup no what's what's coming up
next for you in the chess world they're
actually tomorrow I fly to Uruguay where
the world championships and the 14th or
on the 18 are taking place and for the
first time I'm gonna coach some German
youngsters there and incidentally Europe
wised
the home of my mom so I've been there
many times and I was happy to have the
opportunity to basically go back there
since I haven't been for six years
very cool well good luck with that I
appreciate you joining me let's go to
dinner
it's Grandmaster from Germany Georg
Meyer the champion of the 2017 Fall
Classic third place is Poland's darius
spirits from slough who scored five out
of nine he walks away with $3,000 second
place
oh so close he just lost in the playoffs
also from Slough it's euros Arabic
five and a half out of nine and after
playoffs he is the undisputed champion
of the Fall Classic from Germany
Georg Meyer Meyer walks away with the
top prize $6,000
while Group A went all day
Group B couldn't have been more of the
opposite in fact
Josh free Bell put the nail in the
coffin early on and clinched the entire
section early the first game that ended
all day he won with black against angel
Arriba's group B's gold silver and
bronze here we go tied for second and
third place our Alan Pietra of Argentina
and Antonio spot ladies of Greece they
will split the second and third prize of
2500 and $2,000 respectively both
players scored six points and excellent
showing and both were at the top of the
leaderboard the entire time and the
Group B champion clinched it quite early
it's Grandmaster Josh free del one of
the frequent chess club competitors and
a veteran of the US Championships he
finishes with six and a half points and
leaves with a nice four G's Group B was
over quite quickly because Grandmaster
Josh Reed L needed a win and he got it
against Grandmaster angel Arriba's Josh
congratulations on your Group B victory
it's great to have you back in the
studio what were your thoughts coming
into today's game well it's a nice
situation to be in because um half a
point ahead and um hell is very strong
player but he's struggling this
tournament and so I figured I would play
solidly but at the same time I really
didn't feel like playing well so I would
definitely look for my chances and
fortunately for me he walked into some
analysis and ended up with a very bad
position right away
show us what went wrong for arenas so
he played the Scotch which he he does
and I saw you played this move once it
was one of many things he plays d5 and
Queenie - is kind of a new trend so I
looked at this D take C for move Bishop
takes e4 as possible also but then you
can simply take the bishop and go to an
end game with two bishops and okay your
pawns are crippled but I think black is
doing just fine here
so Knight c3 is what they do Bishop
before Bishop takes e4 so in this
position I could have played Bishop
takes c3 and takes e4 Queen e7 and it's
basically almost dead equal but I
thought that this move was more
interesting when I analyzed it and again
I don't think it necessarily changes the
evaluation but it's a more interesting
move so he takes on c6 which you pretty
much have to do rook b8 and this is
where things went wrong so castles I
think is the best move
and then black continues with Queen d6
with ideas of hitting the bishop if the
bishop moves the wrong way you have
Bishop a6 and a g4 comes it's kind of an
interesting position I think but black
definitely has compensation with the
pawn he played Bishop e3 which just
looks very natural
but after an edgy four I think White's
just in huge trouble because white can't
cancel here because of Queen d6 hitting
the bishop and threatening mates and he
follows up by taking on a7 which is his
idea but after Queen f6 just way too
much as hanging bishops hanging Knights
hanging with check and then he loses the
rook if he tries Queen e4 check here I
have Queen e5 check and this is the
reason I didn't take first because now
after Bishop b4 and this may not be
necessary but I thought if I'd taken
first you could play Bishop b4 whereas
here I think he's just just losing
because if a bishop goes back all the
way I take this guy and
this is gonna be bad news here jack
takes it to I mean it's just over um so
he did what was very naturally Castle
queenside which is probably his best
option but after it takes takes Queen
takes c6 and I take on c3 he's really
pressed for Moops he played Queen e7
which was a bit unexpected I thought he
would try Queen d3 and then my plan I
believe was to play and I should say
that I didn't remember my analysis on
this particular line so I had to figure
this out so of course things could be
wrong but my idea was to check of course
I don't trade Queens and then Queen e5 I
was debating between Queen e5 and some
other move but I like Queen e5 and idea
is that if allowed I'm gonna play Knight
takes f2 simply and I'm also keeping the
bishop from getting back in the game it
can't go to a 7 because the Queen a 5
check so I thought something like rook
e1 Queen a four check and even just
takes on f2 and I thought that this was
rather promising for black but again I I
wasn't 100% sure during the game he
played Queen e7 and then after Bishop a5
I could play check and try to go back
but I thought it was less clear than
when I did I just grabbed this pawn very
boring but I'm just gonna take one of
his rooks Bishop e6 was maybe also
possible but I didn't see like a clear
win I should just show this quickly
after a rook at the 8th it looks
ridiculous but I didn't see a win here
so I can obviously check till then let's
I didn't say when so I went for this and
we ended up trading to an end game where
I think you know it looks like my night
is is trapped but the problem is I can
always get it out by advancing my pawns
and I can even leave it there for a long
time because what white can't ever take
it and just advance my King start taking
pawns eventually just pushed and
obviously you could have played this out
more but he decided to call it quits
here well Josh a you know you work
efficiently you work quickly in the
final day so that's that's nice and like
you said no playoffs up what's next for
you on your chest calendar
I don't have too much for the fall I
played quite a bit a lot over the summer
at least for me but my plan was to play
in Mexico in December so hopefully
that'll work out I you know always
wanted to play there and that's
basically my next major tournament so
sounds good four thousand dollars richer
the Group B champion of the Fall Classic
Josh Vidal thank you very much for
joining me it's been one heck of a
tournament here is the total prize
breakdown for both fields keep in mind
besides first place if any two or more
players tied they would add up those
respective places prizes and then divide
it by the number of people tied it's
that simple and that's gonna do it for
the fall chess classic the final of this
series in 2017 and we hope that you join
us next year for the 2018 Winter Classic
when we do it all over again we hope you
enjoyed meeting some of the new players
2,300 through 2600 maybe you haven't met
before maybe you wanted to know more
about and these personalities you can
bet are gonna be on the scene more and
more as time goes on so thank you for
joining me Ben Simon and the st. Louis
chess club for the 2017
fall chess Classic so long from the Show
Me State